What does she see beyond
my Zanku Hadoken?
What are you waiting for?
What kind of opening
are you waiting for, Ono?
How can she be so patient?
Finding a foolproof way to win
no matter the means.
Isn't that how to win?
I'm just playing the way that gives me
a 100-percent chance of winning.
But...
what is this feeling?
Guilt?
I don't care if this kind of attack is
contrary to my love of fighting games.
Hidaka.
I don't want to lose to anyone
who doesn't want to lose.
Damn!
Is it possible...
that the chance you were waiting for...
wasn't in the game, but with me?
My guilty feelings caused me
to let my guard down.
Crap! Akuma needs to
take control again, fast!
Final Atomic Buster!
She came from behind
to tie it up at one-all.
While doggedly defending,
she waited for my pride as a gamer
to cause me to falter...
due to my desire to win by fighting fair
and my desire to win
with superior technique.
My desire to win a fight
fair and square...
That's what she was aiming for! But...
My Zanku Hadoken isn't working anymore!
I tremble even when he gets close!
A Screw Piledriver while walking?
How is that possible?
You have to spin the lever around,
so you usually jump.
She spins it with a flick of her fingers?
She is...
truly astounding!
It only makes sense
that she would steal Yaguchi's heart.
If Ono's strength at this is...
as strong as her love for Yaguchi...
then the level of my love is...
nothing compared to hers!